ces formes bi souplesse nous donnerait
pas une sondage c'est pas des tâches
s'était lavé sept étages propre data
d'accueil derrière ses allures d un
ferme
c'est chez toi des chambres 18 patients
18 vous inquiétez pas ça d'appeler leurs
intérêts
attention j'ai piqué alors cette
première semaine
bon j'ai pas mal assuré voilà soit pas
trop sur des toiles tu commences tu
connais rien pour l'instant
quand tu sais pas tu es de monde ces
gens remarquent un truc marrant tu
demandes un patient de 100g sur le dos
besson sur le ventre alors que si tu
précise pas que tu dis juste bonjour
monsieur allongez-vous souplet mais qui
s'allonge sur le dos direct mais si tu
as un mec x et qui sait tout faire
je crois que tu as le droit à cinq décès
par an vié combien par jour mal 40 40
et comment on fait pour boire 40 bières
par jour tout en travaillant je tiens un
bar
tafer des vrais patients des vrais gens
tu t'occupes de vraiment une relation
avec vous savez la douleur c'est le
meilleur système d'alarmé mais chez
votre mari à cause de l'alcool
la larme fonctionnaient mal c'est très
bien monsieur lemoine hier soir voyez
encore il est décédé
et je trouve pas le cg du coup je me
demande tu a cafouillé dans les autres
dossiers j'ai failli y a sûrement le
problème c'est que j'ai déjà fait ça de
fouiller dans les autres dossiers tu
vois franchement je n'en suis pas
possible ce paramètre un espace de
malédiction
allongez vous sur le dos s'il vous plaît
non non et c'est sur le ventre
information à l'aventuré sur le dos de
l'autre côté